[Musique]
l'histoire montre malheureusement que
s'il n'y a pas de quotas les choses
n'avancent pas alors il bon exemple
c'est la loi c'est moman copé avant la
loi zimmermann copé la parité dans les
conseils d'administration des sociétés
cotées qui est de 12% est arrivée la loi
et ses ventes même copie aujourd'hui on
a 46 % donc il est clair que la loi
zimmermann copé donc les quotas ont une
valeur importante pour faire noter les
femmes dans des instances des pouvoirs
et j'irai même plus loin c'est que ça a
eu un effet kiss cool au niveau
international puisque en fait la france
est considérée comme un exemple sur ce
sujet là moi je suis entièrement
favorable aux quotas tout simplement
parce que d'un point de vue historique
déjà à les quotas ça existe et ça a
toujours existé
il s'avère juste qu'ils étaient
officieux et qu'ils étaient plutôt en
faveur des hommes la loi copé zimmermann
une fois mise en action elle a été
effective n'est qu'à regarder les
chiffres d'augmentation de fans conseil
d'administration aujourd'hui on voit
bien que ça a eu des effets positifs 1
maintenant effectivement il ya quand
même aussi certaines limites et on se
rend compte que ça n'a pas forcément eu
d'impact
en tout cas ça eu d impact assez limité
sur le reste de la structure de
l'entreprise et donc il fallait plus
loin effectivement aujourd'hui il faut
avoir une politique de quotas qu'ils
soient plus largement répandue la
réalité du terrain c'est qu'il y avait
des lois en faveur d égalité
professionnelle il y en a pas forcément
que sur le thème il en existe maintenant
on voit bien que le véritable souci
quelque part c'est aussi son application
et c'est aussi sa mise en pratique et
malheureusement il peut y avoir
une sorte un petit peu de jeu de bâton
de la carotte qui peut être nécessaire
simplement parce que les organisations
de travail mais comme toute organisation
sociale ce sont des systèmes complexes
qui peuvent avoir du mal à se mouvoir et
qui peuvent être tentés par le statu quo
si ya pas de carotte ça bouge pas donc
effectivement l'attitude de medef c'est
de dire laisser l'entreprise gérer leur
organisation interne et leur management
et de toute manière on y arrivera la
question c'est que effectivement il ya
eu des progrès depuis une dizaine
d'années puisque en fait le nombre de
femmes dans les instances dirigeantes
quand même augmenté amossy faut quand
même souligner des entreprises qui sont
volontaires qui ont fait les actions
effectivement accents avoir la niaque
humanisation il n'empêche que ça avance
très très très doucement les
propositions de loi qui est en débat
actuellement ne concerne que les
entreprises pour l'instant sinon plus de
1000 salariés
donc les groupes qui ont plus de 1000
salariés vous qu'on est sur une
population qui est là encore très
limitée et les quotas qui sont retenus
aujourd'hui sont des quotas à cinq ans
de 30%
donc on vous voyait qu'aujourd'hui on
est à peu près à 23 24 % c'est quand
même pas très ambitieux et un quota de
40% à l'horizon 2030
donc cette proposition doit on va dire
que oui c'est une avancée quelque part
dans la mesure où var légiférer sur un
sujet pour faire bouger des choses mais
c'est tout sauf sauf ambitieux le fait
de mettre des quotas
ça change aussi la culture et en fait on
s'est rendu compte que une fois qu'on
retire les politiques de quotas et ben
en fait les les entreprises ont atteint
un seuil qui leur permet de battre
finalement d'avoir changé leur propre
fonctionnement est de plus en avoir
besoin
elles vont mettre des nouvelles ce
qu'elles seront mis en place de
nouvelles méthodes elles seront à la
fois de recrutement de promotion etc et
donc donc oui pour répondre à la
question c'est pas suffisant il faut que
ce soit fort tout de suite pour que le
changement soit un réel pour que toutes
les procédures toute la culture en
termes soient réellement changé
tu as eu des nombreux travaux de
recherche au niveau français même au
niveau international qui montrent une
corrélation entre la mixité et la bonne
gouvernance
il ya un meilleur fonctionnement des
conseils il ya moins de chambre
d'enregistrement les conseils sont
beaucoup plus performants
on travaille sur d'autres dossiers
préparés il ya plus plus de questions et
on fait la moyenne d'âge a rajeuni dans
les conseils donc ça montre qu'ils aient
la même dynamique a changé des
entreprises qui ont des femmes qui
siègent dans leur board est super forme
par rapport à celle finalement pas au
delà de salles l'égalité femmes-hommes
dans le monde du travail n'est pas
seulement bonne pour l'économie aussi
bien sur elle et pour l'économie de
l'innovation
elle est aussi bonne pour la société
dans son ensemble est en fait c'est
assez intéressant c'est que l'égalité
lorsqu'elle est établi entre les hommes
et les femmes elles bénéficient à tous
les genres par exemple lorsqu'il n'est
vraie égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes
les hommes ont aussi un meilleur accès
au travail flexibles ils sont plus
productifs dans leur travail ils ont
moins d'absences ils ont des niveaux de
stress personnel et d'épuisement
professionnel qui sont plus faibles
ils sont aussi plus libre de s'émanciper
de la masculinité toxiques
il ya de meilleures relations avec les
collègues il y a plus de responsabilités
auprès de la famille donc oui c'est un
sujet qui intrinsèquement liée à la
performance des entreprises
mais en fait ça va même bien au delà
pour